foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
hi I'm Rosanna Lockwood uncensored
tonight a whole life term for Lucy letby
the serial killer who murdered seven
babies and then refused to face the
families in court will die behind bars
we're going to be looking at how the
system failed to catch a killer in plain
sight
and Mason Greenwood given the boot from
Manchester United admitting making
mistakes over now dropped rape
allegations which field a huge backlash
from United fans is it the right move by
the club
and back in the debate why is Donald
Trump hiding under the covers not
willing to get on stage with this fellow
Republican Presidential hopefuls walk up
the latest
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna
good evening and welcome to fears Morgan
on Santa with meet Rosanna lock we're
back in the chair for another week for
peers now we are going to be starting
Today's Show talking about the
Despicable crimes of Lucy letby
Britain's so-called killer nurse handed
a whole life sentence today for the
murder of seven babies in the attempted
murder of six more
terrifying horrifying the words don't
really do it justice do they it's
understandable why so many of us are
interested in this case and why it's
raised so many debates about the death
penalty and her refusal to appear in
court for her sentencing
it speaks to the worst of humanity how
we deal with monsters in our societies
sunac the Prime Minister saying the
government is planning to change the law
to compel victims convicts rather to
attend sentencing
it seems unlikely Britain's going to see
a return of the death penalty even in a
case like this but what we will
interrogate on the show this evening
with our experts is why people like Lucy
letby exist and why the systems fail to
stop them
a final word as well on the public and
media interest in this case I think it
is vital that we hear the facts of cases
like this and always remember the true
extent of the horrors and the crimes
committed by people like Lucy letby so
we can do what we can to reduce the risk
of it all happening again but let's not
see let me raised up as a figure of
notoriety to the extent that she's
iconized as some sort of True Crime
killer or Halloween costume for the
sick-minded
just as many media outlets now refuse to
publish the manifestos of terrorists
let's do nothing to glorify the horror
of this and let's insist on Dignity and
respect for the families of those poor
defenseless Souls who died at her hands
Lucy let beat will eventually die alone
in jail where she belongs well for
reaction on all this I'm joined by the
former Clinical Director of the
maternity investigation program at the
Healthcare Safety investigation Branch
Professor James Walker
also joined by the criminal psychologist
and podcast host of how to not raise a
serial killer Dr Michelle Ward and David
Crampton whose child was one of 13
children attacked by a serial killer
nurse Beverly allott in 1991. thank you
all three of you for joining us
um really I mean horrific topic it's
captured the nation's attention today
this whole life sentence or multiple
whole life sentences let's start with
you Dr Michelle if you wouldn't mind
because I think the question on so many
people's lips when I've been talking to
them about this is how how can somebody
do this what leads somebody like Lucy
letby to commit the crime she did
yeah you know I think it's it's
difficult given the vulnerability of
these patients or these victims really
we should think of her as a serial
killer first and a nurse second and if
you think like a serial killer you're
constantly looking for low-hanging fruit
I hate to use that word but if you want
a lot of victims then a vulnerable
population like patients in the NICU are
a perfect ground it's a breeding ground
for a serial killer to collect a lot of
bodies and you know serial killing
medical serial killers are not as rare
as we think they are and I believe since
the 70s we've had 90 convicted medical
serial killers and half of those have
been female which is incredibly rare I
mean it's shocking and that's what has
stood out to a lot of people on this
that she was young that she was female
that there is this sense that women
should automatically have some sort of
maternal protection Instinct towards
babies but clearly not the case in cases
like this
that's right and if you look at a
psychopath and clearly she is you can
actually measure parts of their brain
that not only are different
morphologically they're different sizes
the amygdala in a psychopath is often
shriveled it's it's you just don't have
the ability to feel all of those parts
that make us human empathy remorse guilt
so if you happen to be an anti-social
psychopath and your goal is to kill
people that's what you're going to see
now the fact that they are female I
think if you are a female psychopath
drawn to serial killing a medical
profession might be the exact place you
find yourself to get your victims there
was one in your country Jolly Jane Tobin
very famous nurse who killed a ton of
patients and she called it voluptuous
Delight that she would get as she
watched them die
absolutely hideous and you know there
have been notable cases in the us but as
you say we have our own here in the UK
one of which was Beverly Allen The
Killing Spree back in 1991 David coming
to you uh your son uh poisoned with
insulin survived
um I mean this case must have been very
very difficult for you the last few
months watching it unfold
yeah it certainly brings back some
memories
um of course my memories are
um based on the fact that Paul is is
well you know married and now as a
family of his own so I can look back on
things much more dispassionately than
some other Poor Unfortunate parents of
parents of the victims of Outlet
in that sense when you've seen what have
been called the Phalanx um of the
various uh sort of red flags that were
raised at the hospital where Lucy letby
worked and the chances that were
overlooked to stop her behavior
what was that like seeing that happening
in terms of preventing another Beverly
allot from happening
well Beverly Outlet there was a an
inquiry carried out immediately after
the criminal case it was a closed
inquiry the then Secretary of State for
health said it should be a closed
inquiry rather than a public inquiry the
reason for that given for that was it
was felt that people at the inquiry
would speak more freely if they were in
a private setting something I didn't
accept at the time and argued against
I think though probably a very
interesting point was that I gave
evidence in the inquiry and one of the
points I gave or asked the inquiry to
consider is remove Alec for the picture
for a few moments and consider if these
children's unexplained collapses have
been the result of some other cause for
instance probably a a Heather to unknown
hostile inquired infection well this
actually showed in the 59-day period of
these sudden and unexpected children's
collapses was the inability of the
system to respond to a developing crisis
now sadly that didn't appear that
evidence did not appear in the final
report as a recommendation there were
recommendations of course about how
people are employed but I felt that was
a very important point that was missed
and that is the ability to for the
system the hotel the hospital
authorities rather to respond to a
developing crisis are you disappointed
then with what has happened in the way
that the uh letby Saga has played out in
terms of the way things were overlooked
yes although I think things were flagged
weren't they by some of the staff in the
hospital I think the the point there
really is that I think it's quite
difficult although you can weed people
out with employment processes it would
be quite difficult to stop someone with
some malevolent intent it's about making
sure that doesn't become a series of
crimes and indeed deaths in both the
outlet and the let the case and and harm
to others really useful to get your
insights David thank you I'm going to
come to the studio now and speak to our
professor who joins us and you
part of sort of clinical investigations
is something that you look at monitoring
the oversight uh we just heard from
David about what happened Beverly Alex
and the investigation and the aquarium
why there were Parts he disagreed with
in that
what was the main oversight in the let B
situation that has allowed what happened
to happen
well I think the main problem that
wasn't oversight I mean the the
pediatricians flagged up a concern they
had that then nothing else was done and
what's required at that point is is our
independent investigation to find out if
there's anything valid in the concerns
they've they had I mean what um David
pointed out is is two things one is that
this is yet another example of something
that happened before but also it's not
just in a situation like this which is
horrendous where someone has purposely
taken the lives of babies and maybe
other causes of baby collapses which
should be flagged up as a series and
investigated and if this had been
investigated quickly and early then some
of these babies may have been saved talk
to us a little bit about how complex it
is to identify those risk cases with
babies in these very sort of difficult
situations early on in life you know and
certainly not seeking to blame many of
the doctors and nurses that did raise
the alarm because what how difficult is
it to tell when a baby is really
um you know in true distress and may
have been
injected with something versus you know
maybe just one that's sick well the the
the problem is that it's difficult
sometimes but I think in this case
several of these babies were not sick
and and their their collapse is
therefore not unexpected
um so so that was a red flag which was
produced by the pediatricians the other
thing is the number of them uh that they
normally have only had three deaths of
this sort in a year and they had three
within a period of about two weeks so so
that was a flag which which could have
them concerned and they did look at that
but a cluster like that is not
necessarily that unusual but once you
get to 10 within a short period of time
then that is a major concern so an
investigation is required even though
you don't ex suspect one individual but
there's something going on which is
unusual and therefore should be
investigated what about the existing
management structures with in the NHS
strikes you as needing reform at this
point based on this case the main
problem is that the escalation went to
the executive now the executive put in
place as managers of the processes but
they're not necessarily skilled in
investigation or understanding the risk
of patient safety so so what they should
then do is respond by bringing in people
who can give an independent
investigation of patient safety with the
relevant skills and training because
there's very few hospitals have that
sort of level of skill within them to do
it themselves so it's important to
realize something has to be has to be
done there's a risk being flagged let's
look at this more closely and we often
hear this scandals in various different
parts sectors of society you know
internal versus external investigations
when it comes to hospitals and clinical
care what does that mean in terms of who
are these external investigators that
come in well the problem a lot of the
time in external investigators me maybe
other clinicians which are often brought
in by by people who who know them to
look at the hospital and then they're
not necessarily the right people either
because they don't have the right skills
and what we've done in the health the
health services investigation branch has
set up a program of of Investigations
which was run by trained investigators
um along with clinical advisors who then
look to an overview of them and and
that's by far the best way the big
inquiries which I always look into
hospitals at the moment may not
necessarily get to the right depth of
each individual case to find out the
answers and more importantly what to do
to stop it happening again and that is
uh what remains key here how do you stop
it happening again coming over to you Dr
Michelle if you wouldn't mind you were
listening in and all of that and that is
something that would be in a lot of
people's minds you know we've heard here
about how you sort of investigate these
things the safeguarding in hospitals as
well
viewers any reassurance about how you do
stop stuff like this happening from a
psychological perspective
there are there are researchers who
study this and they have found some
patterns that you know algorithms can be
built upon often they take the night
shift
um they often are in the room when the
the fetal demise happens or the baby
dies and I think if you just if you look
at it from those risk factors and you
know as you guys were just speaking
about looking at when there is some sort
of change in a statistical frequency and
pay attention to it a lot of times at
least in the United States the hospitals
just kind of quietly fire the healthcare
provider don't don't raise any alarms
about it and then they go on to work in
another facility and they do this so
that they can kind of shirk any sort of
liability I mean you don't want people
coming in and looking at your hiring
practices and your training practices so
we see that happening here but there are
signs there's a doctor I think his name
is kin kin who studies this and said
that there are very clear patterns and
the two that come to mind are they're
always in the room when the baby dies
because they want to see it and night
shifts very popular so we have to kind
of look to do we have a physician who's
or a nurse who's hopping around has gone
to lots of different hospitals has been
fired from other hospitals and when are
we seeing these changes and frequencies
in the deaths as you were just speaking
about
thank you Dr Michelle and just finally
uh David the multiple whole life
sentences sufficient for you in the Lucy
leppy case
I don't think the justices could do much
more can they it is a whole life
sentence and you will never see the
light of day again
um if I may just come back to the point
about
um the future I understand that the
current in quo posed by the government
is going to be a closed inquiry they say
that's because of speed is of essence
um I would suggest that thoroughness is
also very important and people being
compelled to give evidence in a public
um Arena
with the facts looked out from the alert
inquiry as well as from the letby case
would be advantageous to us all in
helping to prevent such future
incidences is this that's a very clear
message to end with Professor James
Walker David Crampton Dr Michelle Ward
thank you very much for the insights
tonight
thank you
uncensored next tonight Mason Greenwood
is out at Manchester United over now
dropped rape allegations which fueled a
huge backlash from fans is this all the
right move by the club we're going to be
discussing that next
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Minister President Trump Mr President
first lady Stormy Daniels Jordan
Peterson welcome to all these people
protesting just don't get it any of them
don't it's not slightly patronizing
and when you're going through the
treatments you have some tears God I'm
such a softy not a performing monkey
come on Brian and it's something that
really hurt me because they doubt of my
words
a woman is me a woman is somebody whose
breasts hang down to her stomach talk to
marginalized we're supposed to have the
voice I've been a terrible liar
you're being a Karen pass Morgan
kiss condoms to kiss caskets will get
you coming and we'll get you going I
think it's only room for one king man
now I'm saying
[Music]
well there is that reminder that you can
vote for peace Morgan uncensored in the
National Television Awards by going
online and having your say at
nationaltvawards.com or by scouting this
code on your screen right now pulled
your phone up to it like to take your
photo he is up for best gong for the
best TV interview and we all know he
would love to have that trophy to his
collection wouldn't he because he does
love a trophy so do get voting for him
on that very deserving as you saw from
all those clips there
now on to our next Story the evening and
I'm afraid to say it's certainly um not
upbeaten anyway but we're gonna have an
interesting discussion about this
Manchester United Mason Greenwood that
player they've agreed to part ways
following an internal investigation by
the club let's remind you what happened
the now 22 year old was arrested and
charged for attempted rape and assault
in January last year the striker later
had the charges against him dropped
after a cute witness withdrew their
support and new material came to light
United who launched their own
investigation said today that their
inquiries have now ended United
spokesperson saying all those involved
including Mason recognize the
difficulties with him recommencing his
career at Manchester United it has
therefore been mutually agreed that it
would be most appropriate for him to do
so away from Old Trafford and we will
now work with Mason to achieve that
outcome that was the statement from the
club I am joined now to discuss more of
this by Professor Ellis Cashmore
academic and author of the book studying
football and by the UK's first female
FIFA licensed football agent Rachel
Anderson the two of you great to have
you to speak about this hello good
evening and I you know I'd like to make
clear that obviously the allegations at
the heart of this are sensitive they
involve young people
um not here to make a moral judgment
against either party those were the
facts of what's happened that we just
reminded people of the allegations
um and then the fact that they were
dropped and the negotiations that
happened since then and Greenwood hasn't
been playing we've been wondering what's
going to happen to him what is
interesting to talk to you both about is
the fact that the club at this point has
had to almost uh step in and play judge
and jury about what to do with mason
Greenwood's future whether to keep him
on or not I will come to you first
Rachel and just ask you very simply have
they made the right call here
we've made the right call for Man United
for sure because they need that well
they have an asset that they would like
to get some of their money back for and
um he's a very valuable asset to me he's
a great player there's no denying that
but he just wouldn't be able to claim
here that's for sure so they need to try
and Loan him out and try and get some
money for him hopefully with a potential
sale to a country where um he'll be
happy and everyone else will be happy
okay there's a lot I want to ask you um
about your comments but I also just want
to get across to Professor Ellis cash
for and get your simple answer that have
the club made the right decision
no poor decision going
because I think they're showing the
responsibility uh United they're a club
as such I think they should uh at least
give this guy a chance to rehabilitate
himself uh everybody's capable of making
a mistake particularly in their youth I
have I'm sure most of our viewers have
at some point in their lives and so they
should be given a second chance United
are denying this guy there
I mean I'll come back to you Rachel you
were listening to that just I hope you
could hear what uh Professor Ellis
Cashmore was saying
you to respond go on
well
it's not man United's job to
rehabilitate somebody how can you why
would you need to rehabilitate somebody
if they haven't done anything wrong
it is the football club's responsibility
to rehabilitate sport historically has
been one of those experiences where
people from all walks of life who have
made mistakes sometimes being in trouble
with the law sometimes have done
presents at the time they go to Sport
and they find themselves in sport they
find themselves some positive direction
some Pursuit uh and they're usually
constraint and I shouldn't say usually
but a great many times they can
straighten themselves out so I think
football does have a sense of
responsibility in that sense
so that I can understand where the
professor is coming from do you have
daughters or
do you have daughters or sisters or
anything
you have no children okay
because there are certain things that um
if a child misbehaves then you'll give
them another chance but when something
is as serious as this how many chances
do you get you're saying it's serious
Rachel but all charges have been dropped
we're not silly we all know that yeah so
you're not silly legally the man is free
and clear he has done nothing wrong in
the eyes of the law so just to jump into
it he's he's not been cleared from the
point of view of having been tried on
those allegations the allegations were
withdrawn by a key witness
other material came forward go on the
outcome is is the same here's a free man
let's let's listen to Mason Greenwood's
statement in full he said I want to
start by saying I understand people will
judge me because of what they've seen
and heard on social media and I know
people will think the worst I was
brought up to no violence or abuse is
wrong I did not do the things I was
accused of have I fully accept I made
mistakes I take my shared responsibility
of the situations which led to the
social media post I'm learning to
understand my responsibilities and set a
good example as a professional
footballer then he goes on to talk about
the decision made with the club like I
said really complex set of allegations
here very complicated we have to
reiterate the charges were withdrawn
dropped
um they're having this Rosanna is that
this guy is not going to find another
club certainly not in England probably
not in Europe nor even in Saudi uh the
guy has been put out to dry and may not
no longer have any kind of professional
career ahead then go ahead at Rachel
because that you brought up in your
first answer that he would find it hard
to find work in this in this country but
you think he could buy work overseas of
course I mean there's a matter of the
natural fact is that most clubs will do
a deal with the devil and it's just
he is an amazing player and any club
that gets him as a player will get a
good deal it's just about the club's
sponsors they may not be so keen on him
what's the club what's man united is
supposed to do they're just supposed to
what just let him sit on the sidelines
you have no idea Rachel for all we know
I thought that would be how difficult
that would be for the player to never
play all his life as short as it is
he is very skilled and he will want to
play whether it's at man united or
whether it's an other club he will want
to play I know they want to play but how
many clubs are willing to take the rest
let's talk about let's also talk about
the reason why one of the key reasons
likely why they couldn't retain it which
was fans uh they've been women they've
been women fans outside the club who've
been protesting outside and saying they
don't they want Manu to take this
seriously as they will at every other
club
there's been a differentiation some are
saying between the the match day fans
and what they're saying in the stadium
and then versus the online fans who are
probably quicker to make judgment
because obviously we know being behind a
keyboard allows you to say things a lot
more quickly so so in terms of the
pressure that the club is facing how has
that influenced things Rachel
well they have an industry that they
have to they have to protect it you know
they have
um their sponsors Etc and
the sponsors are a factor in the next
sorry go on Ellen sorry the responses
are a factor in the next reckon now
I've always reckoned that sponsors are
in the mix I didn't say they were maybe
and it does had something I just think
that you you're you're
the fact that you're saying that man
united should keep him
to rehabilitate him I've never heard
anything so ridiculous to be honest um
Professor I also want to are they
professors let me just remind Rachel uh
uh and I think she may recall their
encounter not incident I mean it was a
long time ago 27 years or what whatever
uh this is a guy that was convicted and
sentenced to jail time he didn't serve
it initially because he appealed it but
Manchester United stood by Cantona in
fact they pursued him they they went cap
in hand to ask him to come back
convicted
it's the point that I know there have
been previous examples of Sportsmen and
footballers who have broken rules and
been you know charged and convicted even
and have remover clubs is this not a
sign of the times changing it is yeah it
precisely right the times are changing
very yeah they they've changed
uh colossally since the metoo movement
again momentum which is a great thing of
course but it is symptomatic of the
world in which we live that no one is
prepared to stand by someone who is in
the eyes of the law Innocent but has the
stigma attached to him uh or her as the
case may be charges
the childish withdrops or the case
didn't continue because a witness
withdraw I would like to know what the
percentage is from someone far cleverer
than me will be able to tell me the tiny
percentage of cape rate cases or sexual
assault actually go to trial because
invariably it's if it's a sexual assault
against a female it's the female that
withdraws because of the pressure and
the
terrible situation I mean there are
thousands of rapes unfortunately every
year of which a tiny tiny percentage
goes to court let alone get convicted
Rachel we do also have to clarify of
course that the charges were withdrawn
and dropped but hearing your point um
loud and clear both of you we have to
end things there really appreciate it
though it's been fascinating thanks so
much
thank you
well on censored next tonight as the
ancestors of British Prime Minister
William Gladstone traveled to the
Caribbean to apologize for their
families ties to slavery we ask does
this open more families up to being held
accountable their relatives history
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think there's only one for one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
whoop me off shorts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air
thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to unscented now the family
of Britain's most famous prime minister
will travel to the Caribbean this week
to apologize for the family's historical
ties to slavery William Gladstone's
Father John was one of the largest slave
owners in the British West Indies the
visit by the ancestors of the former PN
coincides with the 200th anniversary of
the 1823 rebellion in Ghana
in a joint statement they said they
believed their ancestors actions
amounted to a crime against humanity so
is this just the tip of the iceberg for
families of slave traders to debate this
I'm joined by my pack here in the studio
talk TV contributor Esther kraku former
newspaper editor Emily Sheffield and the
co-founder of momentum James Schneider
thank you all three of you now Esther I
know you're no stranger to this
conversation you've had it a few times
on television before
um I think there's it's coming back
around again because Gladstone is
obviously such a big name in this
they're going to Guyana what struck me
about this is the reparations figure I
think it's somewhere around a hundred
thousand pounds um it's going to be used
to pay for Research into the impact of
slaver it seems like a good cause a
hundred thousand seems to me a bit small
I mean obviously there is always the
question of well if you're going to do
this then you really need to bring the
you know bring back the whole value of
of how much these slave owners were paid
off
um but there's the question of because
for me this conversation has been in the
public space for a while now we know the
issue issues of where does it stop you
know Africans were also trading Africans
the Arab slave trade Africans was the
most barbaric they're actually more
enslaved people on the planet now as we
speak than they were at the height of
the slave trade they're all these
questions which I'm sure they're
familiar with for me I think what
strikes me is this is a very public kind
of exercise of spit shining their Halos
right if you're going to do this why do
we need to know about it for me it's
like you know a homeless giving a
homeless person 10 pounds and filming it
and putting on social media to show how
virtuous you are I have no problem with
how they want to spend their money I
would like them to give me the hundred
thousand pounds I could certainly use it
could you use a hundred thousand pounds
that's such a mean I think that's true
attitude to have that's true they're
making a public apology which many of
these um countries Kiana included are
demanding from people who doesn't go
ahead and do it they do it publicly and
you're going oh I just think it's
shining the thing come on
it doesn't help what you want them to do
apologize
this is why ultimately I do not care how
they choose to spend money or how they
choose to behave it's not about the
money you just complained you said you
think it's spit shining their Halo
because why did they need to make it
public yes in the Caribbean have been
calling for public apologies they go
ahead and do it and yeah they don't just
call for public apology
that you can they also call for
reparations you can apologize a million
times but if they don't feel like
they're actually getting reparations if
you're actually trying to rectify the
wrongs of the past they're not going to
stop it's not they're not just asking
for an apology they're also asking for
reparations that's arguing about whether
the hundred thousand figure is right or
not and we could you know everyone could
keep arguing that has to be originally
paid 14.6 billion if they have that
money they probably don't have that
money so they've settled on something
that maybe as a family they can afford
right now okay so people just trying to
wipe the Slate clean well I shouldn't be
wiping this late clean it should be the
beginning of something larger I think
it's the same the 100 000 is a symbolic
amount and who knows how much money they
have
um but the point is it's important that
it's public because we're talking about
it we haven't wrestled with our Colonial
history and exactly as Emily was saying
in the English-speaking Caribbean they
really want to have this debate and they
and it's important uh for them to know
that lots of the wealth that was
gathered up here not by the majority of
people in this country by a few very
rich families was off the backs of their
ancestors and so but they want to be
having that debate so should my this is
not a boundary case
there are loads of Irish people that
would like reparations are you going to
be the first in line to give them some
several points I said one this is a
public exercise and I'm spit showing
their Halo which it is no one needs to
know about them they're not more
virtuous this doesn't help anyone but
also if we're talking about slavery
reparations which we are if we're
talking about slavery reparations there
were loads of people that were slight
from various parts of the world where
does this end and no one wants to answer
that question because they know it is
ludicrous and you will never have
anything this is very obviously not a
boundary case though right you've got
somebody who's whose son became prime
minister who was who his son spoke in
parliament against abolishing the slave
trade it was on his Plantation that the
Demerara uh slave Uprising began he did
by the way change it later on in his
career I mean he was a great lip you
know he did switch sure but the the the
money that he got he was I think the
third biggest recipient of compensation
that his father was his father was the
third biggest so for that family part of
the reason why they've got so much money
presumably today is because they got
paid off for first of all because they
did slavery and then they got paid off
for it but you can extend that argument
anywhere part of the reason why we're
sitting here in you know in this very
well the successful country for instance
is off the back of many people and
basically being enslaved in parts of
China do we have to do the same thing
the reason why I'm making the point as
to where this is end is because we are
all everyone sitting in this room are
beneficiaries of some sort of slavery at
some point a lot of it modern and
current what what is your shirt from
right this is true no because I can make
the argument about this and I love you
rock I love you around here I love you I
think we should take it further I think
this should be a starting point no one
gets the Slate White theme from this the
starting point for this should say oh
now we really should talk about why
there is such Injustice between for
example Guyana or the English character
and the UK do you Rectify by just giving
them more money no I would if you know
change the trade system change Global
patents change economic structures those
are the things that we could do long
term and you could unite the majority of
people in Britain and the majority of
people in uh former colonized countries
because the majority of people in
Britain also were uh exploited by the
the ruling class in this country they're
also hyper exploited the ruling classes
bringing Emily back in because what's
interesting about what we're hearing
between this is also the voluntary
nature of it it's not mandatory like you
said Guyana demanding or some some
Caribbean countries are requesting uh
but it's up to these families
individually to decide whether or not
they do it do you think the Glad
students are doing the right thing here
and do you think they're doing the right
way I do think they're doing it the
right way and the trevellians did it
just before and I I think that it is
right I don't think they're just trying
to spit shine their Halo they're
actually putting their the history of
their family and who they are massively
in the spotlight they're welcome to do
that well I don't I don't know who this
guy is I didn't know William Gladstone's
relatives
um I didn't really know about the
trevellians either so they're actually
putting themselves massively in the
spotlight so I don't think they're
trying to Halo themselves
I think generally they're part of a
movement that is is is huge and well
you've just touched on the point of it
being a movement and they are quite
right but you seem to be my my point was
just that it's good
this is the biggest manifestation of
white guilt you ever see and it you know
for me it's it's an extension of white
privilege but I will say this the reason
why we're having this conversation
because this is one family that we don't
know we're not friends with they're not
our family members but the reason why
we're having this conversation is
because they're wider implications
there's always going to be a wider
societal implication in California for
instance they're trying to spearhead you
know slavery reparations even though
California was not a slave state most of
the people there are not safe they're
reparations for racial discrimination no
no they're for adults adult descendants
of slaves that's that's the group that
the uh and I know this and I know this
and I know this because I have relatives
that live in San Francisco who are
Afghanistan who actually ironically
benefited from the slave trade because
their ancestors made a lot of money off
of it but again people want to be a
historical whenever we talk about these
things the point I'm making is I don't
care what the Gladstone is want to do
they're one family they have more money
than God give me some please but do what
you want with it but the the the the
bigger point I'm making is the wider
societal implication if we're going to
have some sort of eventually some sort
of reparations tax or they're going to
look into people's Bloodlines actually
your mixed race so you get half you pay
half reparations and give half of it
back it's so complicated and it's so
complex and this is just an unnecessary
exercise yes in spit shining their Halo
there are a bunch of white people that
feel guilty and they think they're doing
they're benefiting you know what if you
really want to benefit people that are
former Colony slaves go to sub-Saharan
Africa trust me there's a lot there's a
plethora of charity work you can do
there plethora I never thought we'd talk
about spit shining Halos so much for the
show SD really got everyone talking with
that comment esta and Emily and James
thank you very much really fascinating
uncensored next to Nike is Trump Running
Scared by not appearing at this week's
Republican presidential candidate or is
he just confident he's got parties full
backing we're going to be debating that
next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
coming up on the talk the families of
Lucy let these victims call for a change
in the Law to force criminals to appear
in court for sentencing virgin radio's
Chris Evans Reveals His shock skin
cancer battle a Manchester United part
ways with Striker Mason Greenwood after
an attempted rape charge against him was
dropped earlier this year that's all at
nine o'clock
foreign
welcome back to uncensored and to the US
now President Joe Biden finally on route
to Hawaii as we speak to inspect damage
and meet with survivors of the wildfires
that have ravaged Maori at least 114
people have died after fires broke out
on the island on August 8th last week it
saw hundreds of people are still missing
while into our neighborhoods and
historic landmarks have been reduced to
Ash the president is expected to touch
down in the next 30 minutes or so where
he's going to be meeting with federal
state officials and local leaders
following criticism for his response to
the disaster for more on this I'm joined
from Hawaii by Fox News weather
correspondent Robert Ray Robert I know
you've been all over this story uh the
last few days first of all just in case
because you know obviously we're
International here we're broadcasting
from London to various places if our
viewers aren't totally up to speed just
give us a sense of the devastation of
what happened there
yeah well good evening to you and good
morning from Hawaii you know as you
stated President Biden on his way
expected to land uh shortly where he'll
take an aerial tour and then hit the
ground into the town of Lahaina 12 000
people used to live there that town is
gone uh and the death toll continues to
rise well over 100 and 800 people we are
told by officials that are unaccounted
for and I can tell you you know here we
sit here about two weeks after uh this
wildfire and there are over 1 000
Federal Personnel on the ground
everywhere from the FBI to the ATF to
the DEA still searching for any human
remains in that charred Town DNA swabs
have to be taken by relatives of the
unaccounted for and so this is a process
that continues to unfold and meanwhile
lawsuits are beginning there are
individuals that survive that have lost
everything that are now suing the
utility and electrical power companies
here claiming that you know the fact
that the power lines fell down during
those heavy winds 70 to 80 miles per
hour during those gusts from the
remnants of Hurricane Dora and that
spread the fire caused all that so the
lawsuits are coming and I've talked to
attorneys about that I've also talked to
Federal sources telling me that on the
ground here you know there is some
confusion as to how they're going to
maintain all of these human remains and
try to get an accurate count for the
dead they're flying more coroners in
from the mainland U.S to go through this
process to try and identify what's left
not to be too graphic but in some cases
it is just dust or particles of human
beings and so Joe Biden and the first
lady today will meet with officials they
will tour I can tell you
everyone I've talked to here I'd say 90
of the people have no interest in having
the president on the ground here at all
they don't want politics involved in
this they want action uh they want uh
more funds to be given to them at this
point seven hundred dollars uh by FEMA
has been given to those who are
displaced and people think that they
need more uh obviously and there are
some people that have applied for that
money and have been rejected even though
they've lost everything so you know the
Hawaiian Islands here Maui specifically
is where we're at out 2 500 miles in the
Pacific Ocean uh just reeling right now
as the president United States about to
show up is that going to do any good
according to the people here no wow
Robert you really painted the picture
there the devastation what the people
want and what this visit means or
doesn't mean to then Robert Ray Fox
weather reporter thanks so much
well let's stay in the US now Donald
Trump has confirmed he's not going to
take part in the upcoming Republican
presidential debate that is scheduled
for Wednesday in a post on his very own
truth social platform yesterday the
former president Trump confirming he
won't be attending because of his
legendary numbers in the polls but Trump
is facing backlash from other candidates
including the DeSantis campaign who said
he should show up and earn his
nomination his former friend and
Republican candidate Chris Christie also
had this to say
scared to show up on stage and debate
you and I do think a lot of other people
agree I do think it's specifically about
you if he believes he should be the
nominee if he believes that he's got
such a great record if he believes he's
the best person to go against Joe Biden
then show up on Wednesday night and stop
being such a coward
well firm words there is the former
president Trump popular enough then to
get away with all this or will it
actually hinder his campaign joining me
now to talk about it is conservative
talk radio host Ben Ferguson and from
New York former Republican member of the
House of Representatives John
libertilier thanks gentlemen very much
for joining us uh to give off a sense of
this
um I was talking to the producers
earlier and we're sort of pontificating
is this you know a brilliant 4D chess
move from Trump thinking ahead as ever
putting himself outside of the debate
doing his own thing and marking himself
out as different or is he just being a
coward John
I think it's half
afraid of eight or nine other candidates
standing there for two hours hitting on
him the whole night and attacking him I
think that's part of it and the other
half is I think his lawyers are begging
him to shut up and not go public
uh on these debates and press
conferences and he's going to end up
talking about the case and hurt himself
so I think he's sort of torn he loves
the attention but he did listen today he
was supposed to hold a press conference
in bed Minister about Georgia he
listened to the lawyers and canceled it
I'm pretty sure they're leaning on him
not to do this debate yeah let's remind
ourselves that he actually said last
week he was going to release this report
about the Georgia 2020 votes and he said
rather than releasing that report as he
had promised to do so he said he's been
listening to his lawyers would prefer to
put this informal legal filings Ben is
he finally listening to his lawyers I
think he's listening to them on this
issue in Georgia not having the press
conference uh but I don't believe that
the lawyers had anything to do with the
decision of him not to show up for the
debate traditional it's not a brilliant
move it's just a traditional political
move all over the country if you are so
far ahead of everyone one else in a poll
there's nothing good that comes from you
debating it's it there's there's no
reason to do that to waste your time or
to take the risk I mean you look at the
CBS poll which is not a place that loves
Donald Trump Donald Trump the the poll
that came out today he's at 62 percent
DeSantis is at 16. uh vivek's at seven
pins at five and the guy that called him
a coward which really made me laugh
Chris Christie Chris Christie is at two
percent in the polls so I I mean no one
wants to hear from Chris Christie on
during this debate on Wednesday night
and I think Donald Trump is actually
being smart like so many other
candidates are running for office in the
country they understand that when you
have this big of a lead every other
candidate if you add their entire
combined polling numbers there's still
10 points outside of Donald Trump at
minimum in all polls that are out there
right now Nationwide some of them he's
he's still ahead by 20 points so if I'm
advising Donald Trump or any candidate
that's in this situation I'd say why the
hell would you go to a debate you
clearly are the person they want stick
with what you're doing now and don't
change it John coming to you then for
the rest of the contenders if they're
sort of LED mud wrestling amongst
themselves if we could say that and
Trump's over there doing his own thing
what is going to mark one of them out as
different we've got Rhonda Santos at 16
there's people trailing behind a vivid
rabbit Swami is seven percent what is
going to win over this Republican
nomination in that group that could
really seriously contend Trump but it's
such a long way to make up well it's a
great question it's the second time 2016
being the first time you have a
multi-candidated field against Trump
none of the other candidates can figure
out
how to even get to be one-on-one with
Trump
and how do you clear all the other ones
out because there is you know it's
roughly 50 percent in Iowa that is open
to a different uh candidate than Trump
but they're all divided up among these
other 10 or 11 people so
I suppose if you're advising these
candidates on Wednesday night someone
needs to come up with something that's
so brand new and different Allah what
Trump did in 2015. be different and
shockingly so where everybody goes hey I
didn't realize this guy or this gal is
fantastic I had to take another look at
him or her now having said that I don't
think it's going to happen I've seen
enough of all these people they're
actually running most of them Nikki
Haley Scott they're running to be
Trump's running mate they're not running
against Trump Ben is it in the spirit
we've not got much time but of the grand
old party to just not take part in the
debate
absolutely if if you are a former
president United States of America and
you're polling at 60 plus percent and
double digits ahead of the entire field
with all of their poll numbers combined
then you go run your campaign the way
you want to you're clearly the favorite
at this point and look he's also by the
way not afraid to talk he's doing a huge
interview at the exact same time and
what I I'm gonna predict it I bet you
that interview gets more views than the
number of people that watch the
Republican debate because more people
care about what Trump says than any of
these people on stage and if the and the
biggest problem they can have on stage
is this if they if fresh out of time
guys so sorry John and Ben gotta go that
is it from us what have you up to
tonight make sure it's uncensored good
night
foreign
[Music]
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail about working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war please remember me cry again I'm
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning Ma
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
let it roll
oh yeah